You're standing at
this abandoned mine.
You can only see maybe
two or three meters
in before it's entirely black.
But in the kind of haze, you can
see the kind of decrepit, old bits
of previous mining industry
and overwhelmingly,
the squawk all these bats.
Their wings beating
in the darkness.
Oh, you can hear them.
And you know what kind
of species are inside?
And so what
we're doing here is
basically just checking
to see if there's
any signs of hunting.
Yes.
So you guys are stopping
people from coming here.
That's your job.
Masks on?
Yes.
MAN 1: Masks on.
[inaudible] All right.
Let's check it out.
Yeah.
See, you can see
them right here.
[bleep]
Wow.
So there's an entire
colony in here.
Yeah.
MAN (VOICEOVER): This is
the first time in my life
I've been in a bat cave with
bats flying around my head.
But also, in the
knowledge that bats
contain viruses that
are dangerous to humans,
especially in
places like Liberia,
where we know Ebola came
from, where all kinds of other
viruses that we
don't yet know about.
So it really was kind
of quite unnerving.
MAN: Wow.
CHRIS: Wow.
MAN (VOICEOVER): It was a
relief to have Chris nearby.
He was quite relaxed
about the whole thing.
CHRIS (VOICEOVER): For me,
because I'm a complete wildlife
geek, I think that this is one
of the most beautiful things
that I've seen, even
though I know that there
is this potential risk.
And people want these
bats right, Chris?
These are valuable.
In many places, these
are a preferred food
item, where people
will pay almost
a premium price for something.
So this would be a
prime hunting ground
for someone to come in here
and just collect a whole bunch.
OK, so if you came in here
as your average poacher,
you're not wearing a mask, and
there's no real protection,
you could easily
pick up any kind of--
This is the exact type
of almost transmission
scenario, where you are
getting aerosolized urine,
aerosolized feces.
But also, if you're
killing the bats,
you're then exposed directly
to their blood as well.
Wow.
CHRIS: Yes.
Let's walk in a little bit.
Wow, it just keeps going.
This is absolutely insane.
A lot of the old, iron
ore processing equipment,
I'm guessing.
Is that right?
And you guys, what
are you looking for?
What have you found?
Moses, what is that?
CHRIS: So a poacher came
in here and set that up.
Yes, exactly.
Yes.
MAN (VOICEOVER):
Moses and his team
find this trap, which
seems to suggest
that humans have been inside.
CHRIS (VOICEOVER): So you
have hunters, who were staying
in this cave night after night,
being exposed to bat feces,
bat urine, bat bites.
There's actually a horseshoe
bats and a type of fruit bat.
Horseshoe bats are known
to be related, potentially,
to COVID and also to Ebola.
Oh, wow.
Oh, my God.
CHRIS (VOICEOVER): And we
go further and further back
into the depths of the cave.
And Moses looks down.
And he actually
sees a whole host
of dead bats on the ground.
CHRIS: Wow.
This is insane.
MAN: This is a baby.
CHRIS: Yeah.
Oh, my God.
This one is probably a
juvenile or sub-adult. This
one's definitely a juvenile.
So what caused this one to die?
So you almost
wonder if there was
some sort of disease that spread
through this community of bats.
It would certainly
explain why do
you have a variety
of different age
classes of bats that are all
dead in the exact same spot.
It feels like this
is something that's
really important to understand.
MAN (VOICEOVER): And Chris
is fascinated by this.
And it could be
that these bats have
died of some kind of virus.
It really does feel like
we're in a front line
of something unknown.
Young bats should not
be dying basically.
Not like this.
And I think,
obviously, the issue is
if there's a poacher in
here, and there's a dead bat,
and there's blood or whatever,
so there's a problem.
So there's probably
some sort of disease.
Exactly.
CHRIS (VOICEOVER):
Bats were known
to be the reservoir of Ebola.
It also transmitted to
other types of animals
and then was
transmitted to humans.
This is the exact way that a
new deadly virus could start.